Blade Runner Blade Runner 20:49 and you
play this character I love this
character he's a blind is villain he's
blind he's so soft-spoken it's this very
subtle performance incredibly eerie
performance but I find I think it works
beautifully
I appreciated the the script was
incredible I got to work with Harrison
Ford one of my heroes and it was it was
it was an experience I'll never forget
I mean I absolutely loved it the film
which comes out I believe tomorrow yeah
and everyone's invited to go because
it's just a really special one I think
the director is is is one of the the
most incredible directors working today
and it was an absolute pleasure well we
have a clip here and this is a clip from
Blade Runner 20 49 I think this is just
after you've created a new artificial
life yeah and I believe we're seeing you
in sort of part of that process yeah
exactly I was taking this clip from
Blade Runner
20:49 now this have a Lucas you
[Music]
we make angels funny because while we
were showing the clip Jared leaned over
to me and he went why'd they send you
this clip nothing happens
cuz I think they don't want to give
anything away yes something does happen
Yeah right after that I promise yeah but
they don't want they don't want you to
copy okay
you